il ya deux éléments qu'il faut toujours
garder à l'esprit en même temps c'est
que d'une part effectivement les
manifestations sont des éléments où vous
avez une sorte de confrontation entre
des manifestants et des forces de
l'ordre et je parlais de ce premier
élément tout à l'heure où on a une
augmentation très nette des violences
policières
alors que les violences des
manifestations des manifestants sont
relativement constante cinglante et là
il ya une multitude de sources qui
atteste sa par exemple le rapport récent
de l' indice mondial sur la paix mais on
peut aussi par exemple fait référence au
travail de l'association acat tout
l'association des chrétiens pour
l'abolition de la torture mais aussi des
travaux académiques
donc on a d'un côté une augmentation
nette des violences policières des tirs
sur les civils et ensuite on a
effectivement
l'autre élément c'est un peu la bataille
de l'image et et des idées et l'a à
nouveau
eh ben on pourra dire que tu entends le
premier élément la police a en quelque
sorte sa propre son propre pouvoir
discrétionnaire et dans l'autre cas dans
la bataille des images et des idées et
bien là on a aussi un état qui a souvent
tu as lease hl effectivement la police
et on voit très clairement que si à
chaque fois on a un usage un retour
massif aux gaz lacrymogènes ou l bd ou
différentes grenat c'est aussi parce que
c'est par ce moyen là que l'état
effectivement d incident très très
fortement les manifestants à exprimer
leurs opinions et leurs idées dans la
rue
[Musique]